>> Sean: JOINING US WITH NOW
ON THE OUTRAGEOUS STORY THE
OAKLAND MAYOR WARNING
RESIDENTS AHEAD OF TIME THAT
ISIS RAIDS WITH TARGETING
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
JOINING US NOW FROM TOMI
LAHREN AND CATHY AREU IS
WITH US.
DO YOU BELIEVE IN THE RULE
OF LAW, CATHY?
>> OF COURSE I DO, YES.
>> Sean: AND FEDERAL LAW
SAYS THAT YOU ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO ENTER THE COUNTRY
ILLEGALLY.
>> RIGHT.
>> Sean: OKAY.
ESPECIALLY FOR THE CASE OF
THOSE CRIMINAL ALIENS THAT
WE KNOW COMMITTED CRIMES, DO
YOU THINK IT'S A GOOD THING
THAT THE OAKLAND MAYOR, THAT
SHE WARNS CRIMINAL ALIENS IN
SOME CASES OH, ICE IS
COMING.
I WANT TO AID AND ABET YOU
AND HELP YOU BREAK THE LAW.
>> I WOULDN'T SAY SHE WAS
WARNING CRIMINAL ALIENS.
>> Sean: SHE WARNED THEM ICE
IS COMING.
>> I WOULDN'T CALL THEM
CRIMINAL ALIENS,
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS.
>> Sean: FOR GET THE WORD
SMITHY.
>> TAX PAYING, HARD WORKERS
IN OUR COMMUNITY.
>> Sean: DID THEY BREAK THE
LAW?
>> THEY ARE WORKING IN OUR
COUNTRY.
THEY ARE PAYING TAXES.
THEY ARE NOT BREAKING LAWS.
>> Sean: WHEN THEY ENTERED
THE COUNTRY ILLEGALLY BY NOT
GOING THROUGH THE NORMAL
PROCESS, IS THAT ILLEGAL?
YES OR NO.
>> I'M NOT SAYING THEY
ENTERED I WILL LEGALLY.
THEY MAY HAVE HAD A WORK
VISA THAT WAS HERE.
THEY MY HAVE BEEN INVITED IN
BY A COMPANY AND INVITED TO
STAY.
>> Sean: YOU ARE BEING STUB.
>> NOT AT ALL.
THEY ARE UNDOCUMENTED.
>> Sean: PEOPLE ENTER THIS
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
>> SOME PEOPLE ENTER THIS
COUNTRY TO WORK AND PEOPLE
HIRE THEM.
>> Sean: IS THAT ILLEGAL?
>> IT MAY BE FROWNED UPON.
BUT I WOULD SAY THEY ARE
UNDOCUMENTED.
>> Sean: THIS THE SETTER
PATH ALL DEPENDS ON THE
MEANING OF THE WORD IS.
I CAN'T HANDLE.
THIS IT'S OBVIOUSLY ILLEGAL.
THE THING THAT BOTHERS ME,
TOMI, THAT MAYOR IS PUTTING
LAW ENFORCEMENT LIVES IN
JEOPARDY BY GIVING THEM A
HEADS UP.
>> NOT ONLY -- SEAN, NOT
ONLY LAW ENFORCEMENT LIVES
BUT AMERICAN LIVES.
RESIDENTS OF OAKLAND THEIR
LIVES ARE ON THE LINE.
TALK ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS
TALKED TIME AND TIME AGAIN
THEY DON'T WANT TO BREAK UP
FAMILIES.
I WOULD ASK THEM WHAT ABOUT
THE FAMILIES OF KATE STEINLE
AND JAMIL SHAW II KILLED BY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS?
WHAT ABOUT THOSE FAMILIES?
DO THOSE FAMILIES MATTER?
YOU ARE PUTTING A LOT OF
LIVES ON THE LINE AND THIS
MAYOR, IF ONE OF THOSE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS THEN GOES
OUT AND HARMS SOMEONE OR GOD
FORBID KILLS SOMEONE, SHE
HAS BLOOD ON HER HANDS SO I
HOPE SHE SLEEPS WELL AT
NIGHT.
>> VIOLENT CRIME HAS GONE
DOWN.
>> Sean: ANSWER THE QUESTION
ABOUT KATE STEINLE.
>> THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE
WHO HAVE DIED AT THE HANDS
OF NON-HISPANIC WHITE MEN IN
THIS COUNTRY SO LET DEPORT
ALL WHITE MEN.
I MEAN THEY ARE MURDERERS.
>> Sean: WOULD KATE STEINLE
HAVE BEEN ALIVE IF THERE WAS
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT.
>> WOULD MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
BE ALIVE IF WE DIDN'T HAVE
WHITE MEN THAT WERE --
MURDERS IN THIS COUNTRY.
COUNTRY.SEAN
TOMI.
>> ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS HAVE
NO LEGAL RIGHT TO BE HERE.
NOW YOU YOU ARE CHANGING THE
ARGUMENT WE SHOULD DEPORT
WHITE MEN, WHITE AMERICAN
MEN BECAUSE THEY COMMIT
CRIMES?
>> HAVE NO LEGAL RIGHT TO BE
HERE.
THEY HAVE NO LEGAL RIGHT TO
BE HERE.
>> THEY PAY TAXES.
THEY ARE CRICKETING TO THE
COMMUNITY.
>> AND WHAT HAPPENS WHEN ONE
CONTRIBUTE TO THEIR
COMMUNITY?
WHAT HAPPENS IF THEY KILL OR
HARM SOMEONE.
>> THERE IS ALWAYS A BAD
APPLE IN THE GROUP.
THERE IS ALWAYS A BAD APPLE
SO LET'S GET RID OF EVERY
CONTRIBUTOR IN OUR
COMMUNITY?
EVERY PERSON THAT IS WITH A
FAMILY HELPING THEIR
CHILDREN?
EVERY HARD WORKER BECAUSE OF
ONE BAD APPLE?
>> Sean: MY BLOOD PRESSURE,
TOMI, HELP ME.
>> LAWS MATTER.